i i would say those more than outweighed
my little petty oh somebody said oh my
ego i'm so fragile you know but you know
it's not even your ego first of all i i
commend you
first and forem listen i think you're a
brilliant comic i think you're a really
smart
person but then you're just dyslexic a
side that has nothing to do with your
intelligence
you're a good person and a nice person
and and i think that those are few and
far between and you're loyal to your
friends and you're loyal to your staff
and you're uh loyal to your wife yeah
and it pays off though but in a payment
hey listen you got a lot of stuff and it
did pay off you had a number one show
you got a i think i have four cars now
four you know i wouldn't i wouldn't
change anything
and every mistake i made in my life i'd
learn from
you know there's a story i always tell
about uh
why i believe the cosby women
because when i was 19 i was a comedian i
was going to clubs and boss you know i
went to this one club and i said i'm a
comedian in the community yeah the guy
said to me how long have you been a
comedian
i said well i'm about a year a year
he said you got to be in the union
within six months or it's a violation
you know what don't you i go no i don't
know this was the ag union the stage you
know i said no no no you got to be i
can't i can't i can't even talk to you
unless you're in the union this guy
getting this whole big thing you know so
he says hey go down and see this guy
so i can honestly the guy in the ag
office in downtown boston just like
just an empty office with a chair and a
guy in it you know and i go in there how
are you doing
he says are you the guy they did i just
talked to someone so yeah okay how long
have you been a comedian and i said well
almost a year well obviously yeah that's
a violation like i could find you and he
goes on and on about you know the union
you know i said well i'd be glad how
much does he go 300 a year
i said well i don't have 300 and he goes
well how much you got
i said i i got 75 and he takes my 75
dollars right and he writes on the back
of his business cards union man and
signs it he goes give this to the guy
when you go back to the club
now i knew i was being taken
but much much like the girls in the
cosby situation when he invites him up
to the room you think
is this real is this is this gonna be
so
i gave the guy the card and the guy took
the card
he laughed in my face said no okay we
don't need you not looking for comedians
i knew i had been taken for 75
but in a sense
i believed that maybe this was true so
when i would see something like those
women with cosby people how could they
be so stupid to go up to his room i go
he's the biggest star in television he's
america's dad
why would you not
if he saw you and thought you were good
and told you so
why would you not believe him you know
right and so to me so that's
one of those mistakes that just taught
me
empathy it taught me to understand
sometimes people do things against her
by their judgment because they just want
to believe so hard and so much that well
maybe this maybe this is the way the
grown-ups conduct business maybe this is
the way show business works you know you
got to be in this union thing wow well i
mean i knew i had been taken but i
wouldn't change that experience or
anything because
i i mean i remember talking to friends
of mine
all these cosby women they knew what
they were doing
they knew that
they didn't because i didn't know
you know i was naive
you know it's just a matter of being
naive how he introduced me to the
president of show business ones who was
that
i just told him it was the president
did he really i did one time we were at
the comedy store and i said look
i can't remember who it was but it was a
friend i just said you gotta meet we got
to make commission this guy is no vice
president this guy is the vice president
of show business and you were so i ran
over there he ran over there and he goes
my name is lou i'm going to be on at 8.
and then the guy said will you watch me
i remember you coming back to me and
going howie you can't believe the vice
president of show business is going to
watch me tonight
well that's what i mean i mean that's
the perfect that's that's the perfect
case
[Music]